of all the giant powerful armor-clad
enemies and video games the two-handed
axe wielding metallic giants named iron
knuckles are some of the most memorable
from their presentation to their fight
mechanics they're one of the most
intimidating enemies out there
especially if your six-year-old me just
trying to beat the spirit temple in
ocarina of time for the first time
because my sister called me to chicken
to do it anyways like with many monsters
from the Zelda universe their entire
existence is pretty much a mystery as is
they're completely shrouded origin iron
knuckles are also oftentimes confused
for the very similar dark nuts who are
also you know large humanoid armor clad
knight like enemies I mean the
confusions understandable but while
these enemies do have their similarities
their true natures could not be more
different and before I get into the meat
of the video I just wanted to throw out
there that my last video covered dark
nuts and their potential connections to
linked yes you heard me correctly the
hero linked himself and I'll actually be
spoiling that video a bit in this one to
make some of the points about iron
knuckles that I'll be making so if you
want my full theory on dark nuts before
going into this video then click on that
tiny little button in the top right of
your screen to go watch it real quick
then come back of course or or follow
the link in the description below also
make sure you're subscribed to the
channel if you haven't done that already
for all the epic Nintendo stuff to come
but that's enough of that let's talk
higher notes
[Music]
the knuckles first appearance was in
ocarina of time just kidding I lied
their actual first appearance was way
back when in the Dark Ages when horribly
pixelated sprites were referred to as
good graphics back in the 80s in Zelda 2
The Adventure of Link which is arguably
the best Zelda game ever made sorry I
lied again iron knuckles are recurring
enemies and even bosses that link has to
face in his adventure ultimately they
served to replace the darkness from the
previous game Zelda won as the new night
like enemy for the new game their second
and exponentially better known
appearance was in ocarina of time when
they appear in the spirit temple as
these giant emotionless axe swinging
enemies but between their two
appearances there are some pretty major
changes in design that took place the
first is more like a classical looking
Knight in fact their original design is
very similar to that of the original
darknut what with the horned helmet cape
and sword and shield combo the second
and final appearance design is more akin
to a Middle Eastern Knight with the
patterned cloth and pointed shoes they
also lose the sword and shield and
instead fight with a massive two-handed
double-bladed axe that's probably used
for more than chopping oil so the first
question we're gonna look at is this one
right here what's the difference between
the old iron knuckles from zelda 2 and
the newer ones from you know every other
appearance I think it's the difference
of affiliation the first iron knuckles
we see in Zelda 2 are highly enough and
the ones from Ocarina of Time and onward
are Gerudo knuckles if you will they're
similar to each other in that they're
you know big arm are wearing enemies but
they're not necessarily related to one
another to explain that answer I'm gonna
go out on a limb and suggest something
that may sound kind of weird at first
but bear with me it'll make sense I
believe the term iron knuckle that we
refer to these enemies by is less of a
statement about that kind of enemy and
more of a reference to that enemies rank
or level here's why I think that in the
official handbook of zelda ii the iron
knuckles are referred to as being quote
an iron warrior chosen by the king end
quote
it also states that they can take many
forms but I personally believe that's
simply a reference to the different
levels of difficulty they spawn at as
evidenced by the different colors they
wear orange red and
but I want to focus on that first part
they're chosen by the king the King
which king when you take into account
that Ganon is the king of evil and you
know higher knuckles are kind of evil it
may be tempting to assume that this king
of the book is referring to is actually
Ganon the king of evil but the book also
refers to quote the king and quote when
it references the Kings tomb which is
the burial site of the old king of
Hyrule with these enemies also being
local to Hyrule Castle it's safer to
assume that the king that shows the iron
knuckles was none other than the king of
Hyrule himself then why are they
attacking link you ask oh I don't know
Ganon's corruption or maybe as a test
for the hero or something like that the
Hylian knuckles hostility towards link
is not as important to this theory as
what they are which is chosen highly in
warriors now the next logical question
would be does this mean that they are
the fabled Hylian Knights of legend well
as I talked more in-depth about in my
previous darknut theory the Hylian
Knights are actually a group of people
whose Knightly heritage is passed by
bloodline as in you are born into it not
chosen
I believe the Hylian Knights are the
dark nuts which actually fits here
because iron knuckles aren't related to
anyone they're chosen into the positions
not born into them like the Knights of
Hyrule are there's similarity to dark
nuts instead of the other iron knuckles
from other games is due to the fact that
these iron knuckles are Hylian not
Gerudo so that's the Hylian knuckles in
a nutshell elite chosen warriors of
hyrule now let's talk about the real
reason why you're here the Gerudo
knuckles which are a much different
beast now this is where things get real
interesting and just a quick disclaimer
I'm going to piece out everything we
know about the Gerudo knuckles and then
give my guess as to what it all means
but be warned this is a pretty wild
theory you might want to buckle up so
firstly the iron knuckles from ocarina
of time are only found in the spear
temple and ganondorf's castle in the
spirit temple pots are constantly flying
around the place and it's generally
considered to be pretty haunted but by
what I'll get to that later as you fight
the iron knuckles of which there are
only three in the spear temple their
armor falls off revealing a rather
slender more feminine form beneath and
the final knuckle is actually
straight-up revealed to be a brainwashed
nabooru and
for those of you who don't know who she
is she's a garuda leader who awakens
later on as the sage of spirit kind of
really important to Zelda lore the
witches behind her brainwashing and most
likely the ones behind the haunting of
the spear temple in general are known as
the twin sisters Coe take and combing or
together as twin rova these crazy 400
year old sisters are revealed by Navi to
be Ganondorf surrogate mothers which
would explain their you know evil nature
and devotion to their son ganondorf's
reign they directly admit to know
burrows brainwashing and even threatened
to repeat the process which link of
course puts a stop to by you know
sending them upwards in a beam of light
to heaven because he killed anyway
because they were responsible for Naboo
Rose blank brain it's only natural to
assume that they were behind no burrows
iron knuckle status as well which means
we can apply this to each of the other
iron knuckles found in the game now
could a pin and twin where of his
connection to the iron knuckles I'll get
back to that in just a bit let's talk
about Naboo
when she was in the suit she did some
pretty awesome stuff right like she
possessed superhuman strength
apparently summoned a weapon out of thin
air and even had a completely different
voice but unless the iron knuckle suits
were made by Stark Industries this needs
some explaining it's obvious that her
physical abilities were greatly altered
and improved when she was in the iron
knuckle armor outside of it and don't
get me wrong Garuda women are pretty
tough studs but I find it very hard to
believe that Nibiru possesses that kind
of raw strength on her own swinging a
weapon of that size and being able to
smash through those stone pillars is not
something anyone of normal human
capacity can do I think that much is
pretty obvious so where did the
augmentation of her physical strength
come from her brainwashing I don't think
so but that means it must have come from
the iron knuckle armor itself there's
another individual in particular that I
think can help shed some light on this
whole conundrum in the game Oracle of
Seasons the big baddie for this
adventure is known as general owned ox
onyx and even though he's only ever
referred to as a general and never a
knuckle or iron boy looking at his armor
he should look pretty familiar because
it's literally exactly the same as
Dorito knuckle armor from ocarina of
time just draw in a different art style
I mean there's the pointed toes
the printed cloth the same plated armor
and even the same color and this isn't
just some cool looking armor the
developers wanted him to wear no they
specifically recreated Gerudo knuckle
armor in a completely new art style and
in case anybody had any questions
solidified the Gerudo connection with
the symbol on his chest where otherwise
he has no connections to the Gerudo they
were obviously getting at something here
if you look at the other Oracle game the
Oracle of Ages the antagonist in that
adventure is known as Bharat who is most
likely a female Gerudo since she's dark
skinned has red hair and the Gerudo
symbol in multiple places on her armor
there's already a hint of something
bigger going on here involving all this
Gerudo symbolism but spoiler alert
the nail in the coffin is the fact that
at the end of either game it's revealed
that both antagonists of these games
were summoned by you guessed it twin
rova who we know is both a powerful
garuda witch slash with Jazze and
responsible for the iron knuckles of
ocarina of time pretty interesting stuff
right but there's a really specific
detail I want to zoom in on and
highlight the only thing non Gerudo in
this entire picture would be general
onyx or rather whoever's in the armor
even though this armor is clearly
branded Gerudo armor if you look closer
and not to get needlessly racial owned
ox does look to be more fair-skinned
than most of the garuda we normally see
he's also a male further lessening the
chances of him being a Garuda as a male
Gerudo in the all-female race of guru
doze is kind of a big deal so why is he
a non Gerudo here wearing Gerudo knuckle
armors serving twin rova showing off a
pretty obvious Guerrero symbol on his
chest what does this tell us well what
if the point of every Gerudo knuckle
armor we've ever seen isn't who's
wearing the armor but the armor itself
alright I hope you're ready because
things are about to get real crazy up in
here at the end of the game Oracle of
Seasons general iron knuckle onyx
reveals to the player that his true form
is that of a dark dragon from the dark
realm he claims he was summoned by twin
rova now what is the dark realm you ask
great question because it's not the same
thing as the dark world we all know and
love you know the one with that catchy
theme the
our creme has only ever been coined one
other time in the Zelda universe and
that is in the game Spirit Tracks the
most popular Zelda game of all time in
the game the dark realm is where the
demon train is and where the demon king
maladies makes his escape in summary I
believe the evidence we have in the game
would allow us to conclude that the dark
realm is the realm of demons and twin
rova has been summoning entities from
its depths as we see from onyx is true
dark dragon form
I think twin rova has been summoning
these demons or entities from the dark
realm for a while now explaining the
spirit temples haunted status and they
can either infuse them into the temple
itself or into suits of armor that we
know as iron knuckle suits the thing is
these demonically powered super suits
need a host kind of like an Iron Man
suit you know from that one movie or
whatever and if you place a brainwashed
host in a super suit well you've got
yourself a super-powered super soldier
who will obey your every command which
is why we see brainwashed people being
used for the suits furthermore the fact
that garuda women were used for the
suits in ocarina of time and the non
garuda man was used in Oracle of Seasons
this proves both that the suits need a
host to operate but also that the suits
though affiliated with the Gerudo or
twin rova do not necessarily need the
host to share the same race twin rova
probably just used whoever was around as
a host and in the Gerudo desert
that means garuda women this could also
explain why the Gerudo knuckles voices
are so different than what their hosts
naturally sound like because what if
that isn't their voice you're hearing
but the voice of the suit of a demon
from the dark realm and that is my crazy
theory regarding the super powered iron
knuckles of the zelda franchise what do
you think am i onto something
or am i really just insane one thing I
will briefly mention before wrapping up
is that yes there are iron knuckles in
Majora's Mask but commenting on their
relation to Ocarina of times iron
knuckles would mean I have to comment on
how I believe the entire realm of
termina is connected and I'd rather just
not get into that in this video because
it's already gone on long enough
so for now at least they will remain a
mystery hey guys thank you so much for
watching be sure to LIKE this video if
you enjoyed watching and check out some
of my other stuff while you're at it as
always huge thanks to my supporters of
what
I have so many new faces welcome to call
in F Ezra
a nice tone just inside gaming jac
Simmons Felix K plushie 101 Kristina
Adams spawn guy Tim flash K and Thomas
McClure Q guys are so amazing and I so
greatly appreciate all the support that
you're giving me I recently rolled out
channel memberships and the response has
been amazing if you're interested in
getting your name up here at the end of
all of my videos and some really cool
emoji to use in the comments and a
really cool badge by your name click the
join button below or go to my patreon
link via the link in the description
below support starts at just $1 also in
the description are links to my social
media pages so come on over and say hi
that's all I've gotten this one so I
hope you have a great rest of your day
stay safe everyone this is mass antena
bandits signing out
[Music]